aquí veremos donald trump no se rinde
dos semanas después de que el candidato
demócrata joe biden celebrará su
victoria en las elecciones
presidenciales el mandatario aún intenta
revertir los resultados electorales del
3 de noviembre este viernes trampa está
reunido con los dos líderes republicanos
del congreso de michigan una simple
reunión de trabajo según ellos esta no
es una reunión de promoción no habrá
nadie en la campaña allí él se reúne
habitualmente con legisladores de todo
el país pero el encuentro se lleva a
cabo cuando el presidente busca
convencer a los jueces electorales de
ese estado de no validar los resultados
electorales que dan la victoria a joe
biden tras ello algunas fuentes apuntan
a un plan de tron para que el congreso
estatal a fin el presidente seleccione
los delegados electorales del estado
entre tanto el decisivo estado de
georgia confirmó la victoria del
candidato demócrata tras un reconteo de
los votos
working al trabajar como ingeniero a lo
largo de mi vida he vivido bajo el
modelo de que los números no mienten
state ha de poder atenderse como
secretario de estado creo que los
números que hemos presentado hoy son
correctos
los números reflejan el veredicto del
pueblo no una decisión de la oficina del
secretario de estado o de nuestras
cortes o de otras campañas quiero hacer
todo lo que pueda para construir la
confianza de los votantes en nuestro
sistema electoral
trump ahora puedes solicitar un segundo
recuento tanto georgia como michigan son
dos estados claves de las elecciones ya
que cada uno otorga 16 votos electorales
del total de 270 necesarios para
convertir a uno de los dos candidatos en
el nuevo presidente de eeuu